so in my video with Steve Strogatz about
the rock Easter chrome we referenced
this thing called Snell's law it's the
principle in physics that tells you how
light bends as it travels from one
medium into another where its speed
changes our conversation did talk about
this in detail but it was a little bit
too much detail so I ended up cutting it
out of the video so what I want to do
here is just show you a condensed
version of that because it references a
pretty clever argument by Mark Levy and
it also gives a sense of completion to
the broadcast to chrome solution as a
whole consider when light travels from
air into water the speed of light is a
little bit slower in water than it is an
air and this results in the beam of
light bending as it enters the water why
there are many ways that you can think
about this but a pretty neat one is to
use faramarz principle we talked about
this in detail in the Broca's de groun
video but in short it tells you that if
light goes from some point to another it
will always do it in the fastest way
possible consider some point a in its
trajectory in the air and some point be
honest trajectory in the water first you
might think that the straight line
between them is the fastest path the
only problem with that strategy though
even though it's the shortest path is
that you may be spending a long time in
the water light is slower in the water
so the path can become faster if we
shift things to favor spending more time
in the air you might even try to
minimize the time spent in the water by
shifting it all the way to the right
however it's not actually the best thing
to do either as with the brock easter
cone problem we find ourselves trying to
balance these two competing factors it's
a problem that you can write down with
geometry and if this was a calculus
class we would set up the appropriate
equation with a single variable X and
find where its derivative is zero but
we've got something better than calculus
a mark leve solution he recognized that
optics is not the only time the nature
seeks out a minimum it does so with
energy as well any mechanical setup will
stabilize when the potential energy is
at a minimum so for this light into a
media
he imagines putting a rod on the border
between the air in the water and placing
a ring on the rod which is free to slide
left and right now attach a spring from
the point a to the ring and a second
spring between the ring and point B you
can think of the layout of the springs
as a potential path that light could
take between a and B to finagle things
so that the potential energy in the
springs equals the amount of time that
light would take on that path you just
need to make sure that each spring has a
constant tension which is inversely
proportional to the speed of light in
its medium the only problem with this is
that constant tension Springs don't
actually exist that's right there there
unphysical Springs but there's still the
aspect of the system wanting to minimize
its total energy that that physical
principle will hold even though these
Springs don't exist in the world as we
know it
the reason Springs make the problem
simpler though is that we can find the
stable state just by balancing forces
the leftward component of the force in
the top spring has to cancel out with
the rightward component in the force of
the bottom spring in this case the
horizontal component in each spring is
just the total force times the sine of
the angle that that spring makes with
the vertical and from that out pops this
thing called Snell's law which many of
us learned in our first physics class
Snell's law says that sine of theta
divided by the speed of light stays
constant when light travels from one
medium to another where theta is the
angle that that beam of light makes with
a line perpendicular to the interface
between the two media so there you go no
calculus necessary
you